- [Mark] All right.
Alfred.
Alfred, you're the pastor at
new St. John Baptist Church
of Houma-
- Yes.
- [Mark] In Houma, Louisiana.
- [Alfred] Yes.
- [Mark] This is the heart
of Cajun country, right?
- Right.
- [Mark] You grew up where?
- I growed up, in fact,
right across the bayou
from the church and the
plantation was called,
and it's still called Presquille.
- [Mark] So you've been
here your whole life.
How old are you?
- I'm 61.
= [Mark] 61.
And you grew up with both your parents?
- Yes, I did.
- [Mark] Good childhood?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And you became a man of faith
and a religious leader at
what point in your life?
- Oh,
it was 2006.
- [Mark] You were raised
with a Baptist background?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And then in
2006, you became a pastor.
- I became a pastor in 2006.
- [Mark] So where do
you see what's going on
in our country with all the race issues
that are in the news right
now, black lives matter,
what happened up in
Minnesota a while back?
What do you, what do you make of it?
And what does your
congregation think of all this?
- Well,
to me,
it seems like
what's been going on,
no change is being made,
it's still happening.
And
what is the reason
why this still going on?
And this been going on regular
for a short period of time,
you know, it's not a space
it's like every two weeks
or something like that,
something like that happening.
So,
I'm wondering
why this allowed to be.
Well, this can't be
slowed down or stopped,
you know, they're protesting but,
look like the protesting not
doing too much of a good.
The protesting behind these
things that's happening.
So where do we go from here with this year
when it's steady happening?
I don't, I don't like,
taking no sides, but I like righteousness.
Not taking no sides because of, you know
whatever your nationality may be.
But I like justice in the right way.
To me, I think
there's not enough discipline
with the police force.
They not using enough
discipline with the policemens
in the actions that they
take when they doing stuff
like that.
And I think as one get by
the other one believe that they can get by
doing it wrong too.
And long as they continue
not using the discipline
that they need to use, I believe
that it's not gonna stop.
- [Mark] You grew up in the South.
Do you see how racism has,
has it diminished, has it
increased, has it changed
since you were a kid?
- Oh.
Back in my childhood days,
at that time, it wasn't as bad.
And I'm not talking about
the slavery time, I'm talking
about in my childhood time.
- [Mark] There was segregation.
- Yeah.
It wasn't that bad, well,
you had police brutality,
you know,
like it is now.
Well, right now,
a lot has changed from my
time, from my childhood,
when it come down to the law itself,
not just police brutality, the law itself.
A lot of changes have taken place
to where, just it not just being revealed
in a way that it should.
- [Mark] So do you think racism
has increased or decreased or changed
and maybe it's still around
and it looks different?
- Ah, it have increased.
- [Mark] You think increased?
- It have-
- Things are pretty bad now?
- To me-
- Like in the 60s.
- To me,
in one way
it have increased
in another way it haven't.
- [Mark] Yeah, 'cause in
the 60s it was extreme
how blacks were kept totally separate.
- Right, so now I'm
saying in one way it have
and another way,
it haven't.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What do you see the
church's role in all this?
I mean, what do you, do
you think religion can help
lead either the white
part of our population
or the black or all of the population
into something healthier
and something better
where we're treating each
other better and more fairly?
- Well, I know the, the
black denomination Baptist,
is like,
you can tell them
what to do and how to go about doing this
where it will be better
and some just don't take no
heed to it and they fall back
on the church, like the
church not doing nothing.
But the church is not doing
what it should be doing,
I can tell you that much,
we not doing what we,
what we really should be
doing, all of the things
we should be doing, but we
doing I think we're doing enough
and some that still come,
be increased still though.
I mean, be decreased to the increase
of what's going on right now, you know?
But the people got to do their part too.
To make it work, we got to work together
to make this thing come
together like it should be,
we got to work together.
You just can't expect
one side to do this,
and then the other side, not
even trying to get on one
or call with the other side
I believe if we come together,
it'll be so much better.
And like I say, I'm not a racist,
I don't care what color you
are, all of my body justice.
That's it.
- [Mark] I just came from Mississippi
and also here, in parts of Louisiana
there's some very poor communities.
Some of the poorest in the country
and those are primarily
African-American communities.
- Well, that's why I had
said what I said
about the black Baptist denomination,
the Baptist religious.
It's not that
the pastors the preachers is not
putting it out there for them,
it's just that they not accepting it.
If I tell you how to go about doing this
what to do and how to go
about doing, like I said
I was telling somebody the other day,
if you know that
this brutality is increasing
don't put yourself in the way of it.
Try not to put yourself in the way of it.
See, all we look at what
the policemen are did.
But we not looking at
what caused it to be.
For example, if I don't want
no dealing with the policeman,
with the law, I'm gonna
try to not break the law.
So they don't have, I don't
have to deal with them.
You see what I'm saying?
But you got some of them breaking the law
and knowing what the consequences
might be behind it because
of what's going on and all this
police brutality, you know?
- [Mark] But what I've
seen is there's a lot
of black communities where,
for different reasons,
they were kept down.
They're not, they're poorly
educated, very few opportunities
for them to make a substantial income
to support their families themselves.
The whites kind of liked it that way,
or at least some of the whites
liked it that way in history.
And eventually that comes back to snap you
in the butt because you can't
keep any race, any person down
for too long, eventually they're
going to react and revolt.
And that's maybe what
we're seeing now is that
the black community feels
like they've been down for so long.
No?
- [Alfred] Oh yeah.
Oh,
that's the way they feel
like they'd been down ever
since slavery, be honest with you.
- Slavery, segregation-
- Segregation.
- Poverty.
- Segregation
- [Mark] still going on today.
- [Alfred] But when
segregation came about,
we had a little more freedom,
the blacks.
We had a little more freedom
and
we could exercise our freedom,
if we wanted to.
Some wanted to exercise their freedom
go further, some didn't.
I don't want you to worry
about none of that, you know,
but then when it comes down to
where the situation they in,
they wanna point the finger the other way.
So we have been down a
while, but we have been
having the opportunity to least get,
almost where we wanna be.
Some just didn't take advantage of it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
In all your decades of
living in the South,
what's the most extreme
racism that you've seen?
Probably when you were
a kid, I would think.
- Oh.
In my childhood, I'm gonna
be honest with you there,
I didn't have no problem, and
I didn't see much of a problem
at that time, I guess,
maybe I wasn't looking at it
too in order to notice it,
but I never had problem of
another race doing me in,
treating me any kind of way.
I ain't never had that problem.
You know, when segregation came,
we went to the school along
with the others, you know,
and I ain't never had no problem,
not in school and not after school.
I'm talking about me.
I don't know about nobody else.
- [Mark] As a kid, you were segregated?
- Huh?
- As a kid?
You were segregated in school.
- Well, as a kid, I mean,
segregated mean that
we was given more freedom, more rights
to be able to go further in our lives
do things that we couldn't do once before.
But coming up as a little child
I didn't never seen
nothing that was so drastic
and shown racism, you know, I
didn't see nothing like that.
And I never had nothing like
that, that happened to me.
Never.
- [Mark] Nothing like riding
in the back of the bus
separate like that?
- Never had none of that experience.
- [Mark] None of that.
Must've been earlier.
- You know, I can say, I
can say that I was blessed
'cause, you know, I know there're others
that had many problems,
and I had had none.
You know?
I mean, so for, that's under cover,
I might have been,
you know, might've been
racism under cover,
like, if I go apply for a job
and
they give the job to somebody else,
when they know that I was
more qualified for the job,
well, I can't say nothing
on it 'cause I don't know
if that happened to me.
So for job wise, you
know, but everything else,
I ain't never had no problem.
- [Mark] In your community,
in your congregation,
do you think people,
your congregation is
100% African-American?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And do they feel
kept down or just do they feel
like they're being cheated in any way?
- To tell you I never had
one of my members come to
me with a problem of racism.
Like, for example, what then took place
with the police brutality,
I never had a member to come to me
and discussing that to me
and how they feel about it
and everything, never.
So my members,
when something's going down
and if it not right,
they usually,
to me, don't make no fuss about it.
They don't say, they don't, you know.
- [Mark] Are you
optimistic for the future?
For our country?
- If I can have my say with that?
Oh, well.
I couldn't tell you
right now, but I think,
give it a few years, I'll know something.
Give it a few years,
see where it is going.
And how it's going,
where it's going and all,
then I have some kind of
better idea, you know?
- [Mark] It's an interesting time
in our country right now, right?
- Yes it is, you know, right now I don't,
like I said,
I don't believe at this
point it's gonna get better
right now, I don't believe,
you know,
'cause it proved, that was
proven on the other day.
One guy killed and they protesting
all throughout countries.
And about a week later,
another one got killed.
Like protesting ain't doing no good.
See that's what I'm saying, man, I mean,
hey, and
I say there is not enough discipline
on the police force.
I think they a little too easy
going with them, policemens.
They got to be made known
to them when they do wrong
they gonna pay for their
wrong, they gonna pay for it.
But when you give them a slap on the wrist
oh damn, then the next one think
that they can get away with it too.
- [Mark] And there's all
kinds of repercussions
with society and with
minorities after that.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Mark] So we all, we all
have to be very careful.
- So,
it's sad,
but
I believe in the Bible.
I'm a Bible believer.
The word of God and everything
that have taken place
on this earth the Bible
already speaks of it.
A lot of things,
we just ain't have no control over.
It's gonna have to be fulfilled.
Just gonna have to be, you know?
But we got to deal with it.
- [Mark] All right, Alfred,
thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts.
- You welcome.
- [Mark] Good luck with your congregation
and everything that's
going on in your life.
- Thank you, sir.
- [Mark] Thank you.